Britton woke up this morning to a
political earthquake newspaper headlines
capture how Prime Minister Teresa Mays
gamble on early elections backfired her
Conservative Party lost its overall
majority but she vows to stay in power
the Prime Minister's headed to
Buckingham Palace to ask the Queen for
permission to form a new government Mark
Phillips is outside the houses of
parliament in London
mark good morning good morning well what
if they held an election and nobody won
that's effectively what's happened here
Theresa May did take a huge gamble
thinking she could cruise to a big
majority that didn't happen that's
losing Teresa Maher early this morning
looked shaken chastened and beaten odd
for somebody whose party had won more
seats than any other but that's the way
it works here she had lost her majority
in parliament more than anything else
this country needs a period of stability
and whatever the results are the results
for her were disastrous she had called
the snap election while riding a
double-digit opinion poll lead I have
just chaired a meeting of the cabinet
where we agreed that the government
should call a general election she built
her campaign around her leadership which
she called over and over again strong
and stable strong and stable strong and
stable leadership but she looked her
opponent said weak and wobbly refusing
to do TV debates flip-flopping on policy
and Jeremy Corbyn her main opponent
turned out not to be as bad a campaigner
as many thought he ran on an old-style
tax-and-spend platform appealed to the
youth vote
a kind of British Bernie Sanders but
again be aware Corbin is never the
action is corbin still finished second
but for him not being obliterated even
making gains smelled like victory
Amanda cheese got his lost conservative
seats lost votes lost support and lost
confidence I would have thought that's
enough to go but apparently she will not
go what happens now frankly it's a bit
of a mess so Theresa May says she will
try to cling on to power with the
support of one of the smaller parties
from Northern Ireland how long can that
last the betting here Gail is that we
may all be back here doing this all over
again and not too long a time all right
more chapters to come thank you Mark